yeah welcome to this video part 14 of
the Queen World Championship match
series and we're really approaching the
match itself now being in November
already November ninth just eight days
from now from today we see the first
game of the match so part 14 it some
time for a cards game again I'm going
from the black game this time and as
some some of you suggested I have
switched the table to show them game
from the site of our our heroes he am
the serious so let's get ahead with this
game it's a chronic against causal the
former world champion only by am yacht
by a tie-break in the London candidates
um yeah has has missed the match so
kramnik and Carson both had the same
score in London and it was yeah mostly a
matter of luck and the tiebreak that
cards and became the Challenger I still
think a very young yet dissatisfying way
to end this tournament that they didn't
have a playoff alright so back to two
thousand eight yeah already five years
ago this game was played in Viking Z
again the chorus tournament no it's tata
steel and we look at a game that was
played in the 12th round of this
tournament with them thousand um at the
time i'm leading in this tournament he
was um it was the first real super
tournament that he was so close to
winning and of course a crucial game
here let's see what happens Kramnik
playing white and he plays Knight f3 yes
so often see form e 600 classical
opening it seems it's now Knight c3 we
said the time was slight surprise
because Kramnik was so successful and he
still of course plays the catalan he was
so sex or sex while successful at the
time with the catalan that it was a
slight surprise that he now goes for 93
yeah my nose now of course has a wide
choice of setups can go to Queens gambit
on play em yeah an English nuzzo hybrid
wear white probably want to play d4 but
go for one of those moves and that's
also see 5 and this is what he played
this more or less invites edge rock
formation as in this concrete position
white is almost yeah not for us but the
only real ambitious movie is the move g3
and after b6 we get the head shock one
point is that deform is not very young
ambitious here due to the effect you to
various moves one move however is the
simple d5 wear white has a hard time to
show anything at all so g3 is played and
b6 yeah should we do there should be
seven castles and Bishop e7 so we have
this an introductory moves of the
Hedgehog which now is on the god white
takes with the Queen usually white takes
in the Queen in this formation simply to
keep more pieces on the board if white
take with the night and black captures
on g2 and then now or after castles
place Queen's the eighth with the tempo
on the pond and next Queen B sub checks
out something yeah against this
even d5 but yeah let's say him and then
the screen check is having check as a
possibility to to use the King position
Yemm this is just not promising for wine
at all Queen takes and now d 6 yeah
black could play oops 96cm gaining a
temple but normally and the head shock
like always prefers to play d6 Knight to
d7 a 6 it's simply a more ammonia some
setup keeping the the diagonal unblocked
so black goes for this type of formation
d6 a chronic plate look T 1 yep White
has many options here of course look T 1
is some a move that um yeah sort of
delays why its decision for one move and
the decision I mean is some what to do
with this Bishop you could play for a
fianchetto or you could use it on g5
sometimes even over on f4 technically
but G fibers an additional idea 11 point
is if black now castles then Bishop g5
is a bit uncomfortable as there's the
threat Bishop takes f6 and 97's answered
by 95 which is quite annoying so on
black basically asked to play a six and
delay castling for a moment the point
being that now after Bishop g5 97 black
doesn't have a direct problem with not
be five as no a success covering the b5
square this arm on the subtle points in
the net shock kramnik now has a choice
it can still play Bishop g5 which is not
a bad move we can play for a 44 b3 there
are many more
here I ever played Nagi 5 which is a
somewhat forgotten line at the time even
it's it's a bit a bit of a rare line the
ideas after the capture which happened
that white tries to quickly or with the
other night um tries to get an attack
against the d6 bond which of course by
classical standards as a week pawn but
yeah nowadays it is pretty clear that
with precise play on those kind of pawns
are quite often not a big big issue and
this is one of those cases but um it's
um still necessary to play accurately um
the accountant click knight c6 cm were
just as mentioned a bit some uncommon to
place the night on on c6 however he had
to had a specific idea in mind this is
why he played the 96 we will see this
later daddy I mean Queen to f4 still
whoops and not there keeping an eye on
the d6 bond castles and 94 so y term is
playing along the lines I'm I mentioned
putting pressure on the pawn and it is
simply attacked three times at the
moments of black mass term can't defend
it and yeah what is some blacks defense
played night we ate yeah I know for some
of you spectators this might seem like
very weird chess why would black um yeah
retreat the the night 28 and clock up
his own pieces yeah the point is that
okay you need to defend the pawn you
cannot give it away and it's not such a
big problem to have the night only eight
simply because in the long run
those pieces on g5 and inform both
nights they don't really have stable
outposts it some moves like h6 that can
send them the nights away even f5 could
be an idea and so this does this doesn't
look nice but it's just a temporary
thing if your long term would be forced
to have a night only eight then the
position in detail is not good but we
see in the game that it's not a big
problem in fact it introduces an
interesting way to play we've seen you
see now what happens b3 introducing this
idea to increase the pressure Andrew k7
yeah in fact chronic now played Bishop
to be too I think it's clear that after
Bishop e3 which is the more obvious move
it's still not a threat to take because
black has this additional IDM rook a
seven is a very important move and a
reason why cousin put the knight on c6
so that he has the square open for the
rook the rook is in fact quite nicely
placed on d7 as it prepares central
breakthroughs and protects the d6 bond
um Bishop a 3m the Bishop e3 is in fact
are not very effective here because
black happy I had to reply b5 yeah note
that this point is is defined defended
one enough if Y to try to take it I mean
how like that note that here a bishop
banks are not saying sorry so you cannot
take it and b5 introduces this idea and
it's something like that would
immediately give black an HTM this is a
move
it will come sooner or later or before
and here black just enjoys an extra set
upon very nice for black Bishop e3 is
not really helping you don't get the
point anyway so chronicling you should
be too at cards now look this happen
just according to to plan and I think
this is a very nice maneuver it's not
not a new idea and this opening but it's
an interesting setup so kramnik great
look see one getting pieces into play
and now nitro c7 yeah this is a very
uncommon way to play and the head shock
the night is very rarely going to see
seven but it introduces a nice some
setup we see this later Knight f3 yeah
it's a it's time anyway to retreat the
night it's not doing anything on g5 and
it's getting a tactical or it's getting
to be a tactical liability if white
would play and nothing move let's say
something like that then f5 oops and
five just rinse material note that this
is also an idea whoa of the night being
on g7 that covers the square and the
poor only six so I treated and now can't
plate f5 this is quite quite nice I
think from this somewhat passive looking
set up like now play some very active
moves f5 and g5 and it's not introducing
an attack on or leading to a big edge
from black but it's it's an interesting
way to to justify your setup g4 very
interesting taking the night and one
point is that Bishop g5 as we see in the
game you should be five
forces wide to play the movie 3 and III
it's a move you don't really want to
play in this position it's not sound
Phaedra or anything but it gives black
some ideas and those ideas are that the
knight on d5 is nicely placed looking at
those now somewhat we can squares and
the other idea is that if you ever
manage to get a night over to e4 the
night only form would be very nicely
positioned peace when f3 always can be
answered by gtex this sounds like a bit
of a science science fiction scenario
while you never will get there but yeah
not so have a look at the further cause
of the game look f seven kings you want
getting out of the diagonal it's always
tricky to stay the head now see in the
light is some going going to this route
Queens III yeah in fact it is quite
difficult at the moment for both sides
to to make any substantial progress it's
some difficult for white because he has
no natural porn break anymore and also
to some extent applies for black what
pawn move do you want to make in this
position as black it's not you will ever
play d5 you play d5 at some point you
give up d5 don't want to do that and
yeah what else can you do can push the
edge corn but this takes a long long
while to take any effect and Dwight also
has problems to get anything he can try
to push on the queenside but this is
also not hard to not easy to realize the
position is probably around equal so
Luke g7 just a maneuvering and intending
90 form before was played 90 for Queen
to be three and now rook back to e7
covering the e-cigs porn that might be
come under fire from the Queen and the
night and here we have from a critical
critical position Kramnik now played the
move Queen a form which at first sight
looks quite logical attacks here and
here but this introduces a probably on
faulty plan there were alternatives I'm
a good a good way to play um would be
aged form on an interesting alternative
at least it gives white some room here
for the king and it asks black guy okay
what are you going to do with this
bishop on g5 if black takes
then this capture somehow looks
dangerous for him this long diagonal is
tricky it's not fatal weakening or
anything but I think White has made
progress and if black does not take I
can take here I mean if it takes here
Knight takes and some were here then
why'd at least got rid of the Jeep on
and the Jeep on I think is a bit of an
annoyance for white so maybe h4 was the
way to go and it would have led to I
guess very still very interesting and
fighting position in the future it's as
mentioned not so easy to make progress
but once one side gets going it will get
interesting okay Queen a force plate and
ya can't just move the knight to e5
going to this sensitive or nearing
handle sensitive squares around the king
so what should why do it seems that the
best move here is so to play queen bee
three back which is always difficult to
do because you admit that Queen a4 was a
bit of a lemon but why should do that
and still is is ok I guess here ever
take took on a six and this is just
based on a wrong assessment of the
upcoming complications the the big
problem is the mu'fucka is have now the
queen is attacked and jam this was
played you cannot take here this is the
big problem have a look at this and now
the move Bishop to f6 and it's quite
funny this Queen doesn't have any square
everything's controlled by black pieces
and Knight f3 winning the queen is
impossible to prevent
it's quite funny so maybe a around here
Kramnik overlooked something he needed
to play Queen B 5 and had offered to
draw this is something to take note off
okay thank you you can always drive
remember is 2008 at the time causal was
17 years old and he had never beaten
kramnik so I think he lost games one or
two but he had never beaten kramnik so
on the straw alpha is not a complete
joke nowadays i probably wouldn't try
even but you could could try because i
have a look at this blank takes and rook
takes eight when it's quite obvious that
the table has has turned and like a
table stone is probably wrong with white
never had a serious edge but now it's
clear that black is the one going for
when this rook is nicely placed on the
second rank and look at those active
pieces I guess kramnik overlooked
something maybe this Queen D for Bishop
f6 idea and now it's really in deep
trouble check plays rook c8 check can
you have seven and 93 try to relieve
some pressure by exchanging pieces this
is some very good defensive um defensive
concept but connect just keeps the
pressure on not exchanging too many
pieces this is just better than allowing
further exchanges even this is a good
position for black but keeping the
pressure on is probably even better yeah
Roxy to what the else's this piece was
saying so on this retreat was necessary
rook is seven yeah getting this kind of
ideas King g2 and Knight to g5 yeah this
is still
Square and maybeee form is also a threat
that is helping black to make progress
yeah here Kramnik get played rock t six
which does not really help but I guess
he wasn't too thrilled anyway by the
cause of the game and move 39 he
probably didn't have so much time now he
force a very effective movers and it's
basically forcing the upcoming sequence
and here this is such an annoying move
Knight coming to our three we see that
white is pushed back immensely rook a
one and now even trying to get the
second look down on the first rank yay
played a look at you one now you can
check rook takes b6 this is actually
leading to ya to disaster Brooke a one
how do you ever get the night night out
so impossible like just wins this piece
this is an absolutely false made in a
couple of moves look you want made
something like check that checkmate very
nice mate they played Rock do you want
to try to exchange one pair of rooks but
of course black just takes the pawns b4
and b5 and now it's a to pause to the
good and still this dominant position
yeah just pushing the deep on don't rush
yes no no need to to rush things can
just slowly push your porn and combine
that with
the active position and better white
king yeah it's always this made if white
takes him this checkmate will who cost
you yeah III was played and now just
pushing the night back and entering on
the second right now yeah
yeah you do the trick takes 92 but the
problem is that it's just too much all
at once kingi to and after roxy to now
Kramnik resigned he has no way to
prevent the rookie exchange and after
that um the spawn will promote for
instance after King F 182 check night to
be three this will promote yeah this was
the first victory of modern skulls and
against kramnik with the black pieces
Eva and Carlton has beaten cram nigam
really a number of times it's also wise
words are crumbling also had some wins
against the guards and I am Amster I
think that on roughly fifty percent with
I think they have roughly fifty percent
squad not quite sure maybe crumb [ __ ]
even on plus one not one hundred percent
sure he's not on a minus quam does I'm
pretty confident of so I a great win by
by Magnus who took advantage of ya
chronixx in precise play around this
stage I guess that probably here he
around here he realized that he cannot
take on b6 and then he drifted into this
into this bad position note that one
important idea that you can um yeah
maybe borrow from this game and you see
yourself is this type of configuration
with the night on a forum on you can so
always a matter of switching colors it's
could also be a knight on d5 for white
or D 54 D for those central squares
quite often you can cement such a piece
and make sure it is not removed by Anna
campaign
bye bye upon that make sure that the
night cannot be attacked easily would
have three so on this type of formation
can be seen quite often a knight on d5
with them helping porn just two files
away like here the Jeep on to secure
that you for night yeah I hope you
enjoyed this game I'll be back tomorrow
again by a game of the world champion
thanks for watching and yeah let's talk
tomorrow